Đóng có tháng tự chung của cả nước, tuy nhiên người đứng đầu chính phủ cũng chỉ gió, tình đầu cai với Kuy Mô Kinh tế còn khiến tốn, suốt phát điện thật,
và đối với P. Sau Tháng thấp hơn thích bản để ra tạo ám lực lớn để đạt một tiêu cá nâm.
Chuyến dịch có có kinh tế trong nội bộ các ngành chưa giòn nét, tổng vốn đầu tư toàn sáng hội sấu tháng mới đạt khoảng 2,2 gỵ đồng.
Tụ đầu tư a thay sảo tháng đạt khoảng 1,5 gỵ đứng thứ 3,8 mỡ tiền thành phố.
Thủ đường cũng chỉ gió, số lượng cơ sở giới dương sau sát nhập phải giới có lớn, chỉ nộ năng lực của đổng cán bộ các sáng về sây dựng, có người thông tin tài chính thưa đặc ứng yêu cầu.
Hạt tần dâu thông kép nối liên vùng Linh Sá, hạt tần số, điện viễn thông con chưa đồng bộ hiện đại, máo khu, dạm ngheu chưa bình bứng,
vui cơ tán nhau còn cao nhất là người dân vùng đồng báo rất tộc thủ số, cũng sâu cũng sà, tình hình án lên chính chỉ, ăn toàn sáng hội còn tìm ảnh giữa tốt tập.
Thử dân tối, thủ đứng nhận mạnh việc khoảng 3 mục tiêu tăng trưởng 2 còn số đăng là thách thức lớn đối với tiền mình lũi như lâu cây.
Nhận mạnh, một tiêu của lâu cây trong năm hành hữu trong hây sảo lạ tăng trưởng bùa phy năm bình chăm.
Như vậy, sảo tháng còn lại tăng trưởng trên mùi một phần chăm, để làm được việc này và có những đột phá rất mạnh trong tưu duy trồng trên khai hành động của các cấp các hành,
biến những lợi thế của lâu cây thành những dài pháp, giậm bụ của thế.
Chứ khết, bằng một lược trong tay, lâu cây tật trung tốt đời thực hiện màu đam giả ngơn một trong mình trong vốn các giã nổ từ công trên đều bàn.
Chên đàn như vậy, phải quyết tâm đệ nhánh tiền đồ thực hiện giả nổ từ công, đặc biệt là các giả nha tần kết lối ra thông.
Yêu vậy, mới có phần hỗ trợ thực hiện giảm bụ tăng trưởng, hữu đồ tơ, thủ tưởng đệ nghỉ tình lâu cây đổi mới mối mối tăng trưởng.
Dưới trên đệ mạnh ứng dụng công nghệ, kì lối số, đệ mạnh chuyển dịch có ký tế xanh ngàn kinh tế độ lực.
Tập trung phát triển kinh tế gian mâu, xây dựng trung tâm lâu dịch thức thông mình, dệ đại.
Phát triển dụ lịch trở thành ngàn kinh tế mối nhỏ, đưa tình trở thành chung tâm dụ lịch vốn mô của buông tế bác.
Phát triển nông nghiệp xin thái tổn hoàn, phát triển các sản phẩm chỗ lực, sản phẩm o cốt,
gán với dụ lịch dịch vô, chuy xuất ngon góc, mà số uống trong.
Đấy mạnh chuyển dịch có ký tế xanh, gái ngàn kinh tế độ lực.
Còn chỉ phát triển công nghiệp, ký cân chỉ nói rồi,
dụng xanh công nghiệp cao đã chỉ ra tăng lớn và chỉ biến sâu.
Lào cao món có chè dụ lịch, nhưng lại tiếp tục quy đồng công nghiệp và công nghiệp và phát xin là hô nhiệm.
Lại là mô thuận với chính mình, cho nên công nghiệp phát tập trung và những lính vực mà,
chỉ biến sâu và giả trị ra tăng lớn, tôi phát triển,
tôi lịch, ký tế biến mâu, đây là những lịch vực mà chúng tôi cho thành la lào cao có rất nhiều tiêm năng.
Cô vực mà bị thủ những tiêm tế biến mâu,
phải sẽ như những Trung tâm loa gí sách của mấy nhiệm đại.
Nói là tập trung phát triển dụ lịch,
đưa tình cho thành cái Trung tâm tụ lịch vùng và cuộc cả nước.
Trên có giảm kế hạ tần nó hiện đại và sản phẩm dụ lịch đặc trưng và trọng biệt.
Vát triển nông nhật, theo dưới sĩnh tại Tồn Hoàn,
có khách xanh phẩm dụ lịch của lào cao.
Mà lào cao này có rất nhiều.
Cả dưa tự lệ, các bạn sản phẩm nụng nghiệp khác.
Bởi vì cũng đề nghị tình lào cai,
trên khai thực hiện hiệu quả, đồng bộ của hạc tình của hợp với các hạc vùng.
Chú trọng khai thác hiệu quả không dàn phát triển mới,
một chục lộn lực giọc xong hồng,
khai khực phát triển mắc nằm,
bà vùng kinh tế, kia đông, kia tây và chú tâm,
tháo gửa khó khăn vướng mắc,
đề nhánh tình độ các giãn không chình trọng biển,
nhất là về khô dài khó mất bằng,
đề mạnh sự nghĩ các giãn tụ đầu kéo dài ngày trong năm 2020,
trước tục tinh gọt bộ mái mà đảm vận hành thông xuất,
kéo quả chính quyền được hơi khách cấp,
đề nhánh tính độ sắp sếp khoảng lý,
sẽ dụng tài sản công, chú sở rối dư,
chú bị tốt cho năm 2020, 2020, 2020,
tụi bấm đề nghị tình lào cai bảo đảm hoàn thành muốn trường của thông lội chú lên cấp đợt một,
trước ngày 30, tạm năm 2020,
đồng thời thức hiện khẩn chương hiệu quả khíng dịch năm 2020,
để mạnh sự hiện tình giãm thuí tập và sát miệng dành tính hệ khó lệ sĩ,
tổ chức tốt các bạn đậu chiến và thực hiện chính xách nối với người khó không,
thương bây bệnh thân nha lệ sĩ ngân ngày 20, tạm bài.